when the drill reached 14.4 kilometers
it had broken through solid rock and
into a large cavern that wasn't supposed
to be there from the surface scientists
could hear something coming from the
hole they lowered down an instrument
array including a microphone there was
air in the cavern nine miles beneath the
surface but it was mostly toxic gas and
the air temperature was over a thousand
degrees none of this made sense they
turned on the microphone what they heard
caused most of the crew to quit on the
spot for the few that remained
it only got worse they called it the
well to hell
[Music]
when the allies won the second world war
they quickly scrambled to claim their
share of the nazi resources gold weapons
and oil were highly prized but no
resource was as valuable as the nazi
scientific community the united states
launched operation paperclip which
brought over 1600 nazi scientists
engineers and technicians to the u.s for
government employment the soviets had
operation osavea kim where over 2500
scientists were recruited by the soviet
union
abducted thank you this influx of talent
kicked off a scientific rivalry that
would last the next half century nuclear
technology was of course a priority for
weapons and for energy the most high
profile competition was the space race
the soviets were the first to launch a
satellite into orbit the first to land
an object on the moon the first to put a
human in orbit and the first spacewalk
the united states had its own list of
firsts the big one being the first man
on the moon faked not this again no
impact crater the shadows don't line up
pictures use the same backdrop you can't
get through the van allen radiation belt
you want more
i can't do this today if you think the
moon landing was real i have a few nfts
to sell you okay whether the moon
landing was real or fake
these achievements pushed both countries
to explore further and higher than ever
before it also pushed them to explore
deeper a new competition the race to the
center of the earth the american program
was called project mohol the first
borehole was drilled in the pacific
ocean off the coast of mexico in 1961
but the program suffered from poor
management and lack of funding the
russian drilling program was more
focused they chose a location on the
kola peninsula for their hull the cola
super deep at borehole penetrated one
third of the way through the earth's
crust over 12 kilometers down
and these are the public projects the
soviets also had a secret drilling
project the world finally learned about
it when a whistleblower came forward in
1989 he claimed that buried deep beneath
the earth was hell actual help
actual hell he said the russians
accidentally discovered it deep beneath
siberia and he said there was proof
to those who discounted the siberia
sounds from hell's story
it is true
and i for one
wish it wasn't
in 1989 dr dimitri osakov and a group of
scientists were working on a borehole
drilling project in siberia when the
drill reached 14.4 kilometers or nine
miles deep the drill bit started
rotating wildly it had somehow broken
through solid rock and into a hollow
area under the earth's crust this cavity
wasn't supposed to be there when the
drill returned to the surface it was
literally glowing red hot this also was
unexpected the temperatures at these
depths should be about 100 degrees 150
degrees at most instruments were reading
temperatures of over 1100 degrees dr
azakov said it seems like an inferno is
in the center of the earth the next
discovery according to dr azakov was the
most shocking and caused some people to
leave the project at the surface they
heard strange sounds coming from the
hole at first the engineers thought it
was their equipment so they shut down
all the machinery but the sound was
still there part of the research done at
the site was recording the sound of the
movement of the earth using specialized
microphones so they lowered one of these
microphones into the hole even though it
was designed to operate at high
temperatures it overheated in just a few
seconds
but a few seconds was enough to prove
the sound was definitely coming from the
earth's interior and it was unsettling
nine miles below the surface in a
superheated cavern they heard humans
screaming in pain
dr azakov is quoted as saying we could
hear thousands perhaps millions in the
background of suffering souls that
screaming hopefully that which is down
there who will stay there asikov
believed they drilled into hell itself
half of the scientists immediately quit
those who stayed at the job site were in
for more of a shock later that night a
plume of gas burst out of the borehole
and took the shape of a large bat or
winged demon and in the gas three words
were written i have conquered the whole
job site erupted into pandemonium then
the medical staff received a call from
someone we really don't know who kgb
probably the medics were told to give
everyone a type of sedative which would
erase their short-term memories the
soviets used drugs like this for victims
in shock this account comes from one of
those medics who blew the whistle on the
operation hey uh
yeah look i didn't want to spoil the
mood in nothing this is a good story
thanks some history some science demons
even men in black erasing memories it
has it all i feel a butt coming but
is there any proof of any of this well
what kind of proof would make you happy
not picture of the demon would be nice
we don't have that oh well any chance
and i know i'm asking a lot of you any
chance someone recorded all those
screaming souls yep a 17-second
recording has been
on with found show
[Music]
and i'm not going to read the
full article about the nine mile hole
i'm not gonna do it i'm just gonna read
the
email that i got last night along with
what i received
this horrendous sound
now i've got a clean copy of it now and
i warn you
this could scare you
the story of the russian well to hell
circulated for years and even though it
was reported by a few major news sources
who claimed it was real nobody had
actually heard the audio without
evidence it's pretty easy to dismiss the
story as nothing more than an urban
legend but in 1998 art bell host of the
coast to coast am radio show received an
email the email said that there is an
effort to discredit the story but it's
definitely true his uncle had a friend
at the bbc who had a copy of the
recording he attached the audio to the
email after giving his listeners fair
warning he played the infamous audio
that was allegedly recorded from the
whole to hell
i warn you what you're about to hear is
very disturbing indeed
uh what
you know where we can score some russian
sedatives
i don't feel so good
the well to hell is one of my all-time
favorite urban legends i first heard it
on artbell show but how much of it is
true and where did it come from the
story was first released by the trinity
broadcasting network and tbn is a
christian network that operates
television stations and publishes
newsletters in 1989 tbn ran the story
scientists discover hell in both print
and on television the story was a hit
rich bueller a radio host for
christianity today was getting so many
calls about the story he decided to
track down the origin when he contacted
trinity they said the story was
absolutely true they doubled down they
did tbn said their source was the
finnish publication ameno sastia which
was they said a widely respected
scientific journal was it no it was a
small evangelical lutheran magazine so
rich bueller contacted them they said a
staff member wrote the story from memory
oh boy journalism and that person
remembered seeing it in a magazine where
readers could submit any stories they
wanted without sources or fact checking
new york times
no this was another finnish paper yeah
the reader who submitted it read it in a
finished newsletter that covered
paranormal stories before that the story
was in another religious newsletter out
of california and on and on and on the
story was just hearsay and exaggeration
but the companies who published the
story kept defending it you sure this
wasn't the new york times i'm sure yeah
to make matters worse a norwegian
teacher named ogden rendaun heard the
original tbn story when he was visiting
california he was so amazed that
americans were gullible enough to
believe it he conducted an experiment he
got back to norway and found some boring
newspaper article and sent it to tbn but
he included a fake translation this is
how the whole to hell story picked up
the details about the demon it was a
prank made up by someone just to see if
tgn would fall for it and they did tgn
didn't fact check didn't do their own
translation they just saw a great story
and ran with it the media sure publishes
a lot of intentional hoaxes don't they
if they get clicks they sure do anyway
the story has been resurfacing every few
years ever since sometimes the hole is
in alaska sometimes it's in norway
sometimes the demon is just a big bat
but that audio clip is always included
which adds a little extra eeriness to it
and no those aren't the screams of
millions of souls in hell it's actually
a layered and looped audio section from
a horror movie
no most people think it's from the 1972
be horror movie baron blood
[Applause]
as much as i love the whole to hell
story i think we can call this one
debunked these days there aren't too
many deep drilling projects still
operating as of now the kola super deep
borehole in russia is still the deepest
at 12 kilometers cola superdeep has made
some interesting discoveries like
fossilized plankton and huge amounts of
mineralized water buried deep beneath
the surface but no demons no demons at
least not yet but if they keep drilling
who knows what they'll find
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps out a small channel
like this and until next time be safe
be kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you